il était une fois dans le sud du berry
un château fort du 14e siècle qui
tombait en ruine jusqu'à ce jour de 1982
où un releveur de compteurs edf du nom
de richard urbain en tomba littéralement
américain cela mettra s
le château c'est ma maîtresse il ya des
fois j'ai l'impression je peux le
prendre dans les bras
tout commence avec cette petite annonce
on est arrivés par la route de nantes
et puis on aime château là on voyait
bien puis les gars chars et les gauches
qui disait super tu as vu ça c'est beau
et tous les mois je ne savais que
c'était fini quoi j'avais que en allait
changer de vie et qu'on allait acheter
cinq ans à l'époque les urbains habitent
avec leurs enfants un pavillon à
montfermeil en seine-saint-denis une
existence paisible
bousculé par le coup de foudre de
richard attends tu vois ça à vendre tu
l'achète pas tu es fou
c'est pas celui qui l'a achetée qui est
fou c'est sous kg pas acheter la preuve
c'est vrai je suis toujours là au bout
de 35 ans la sphère fut conclue pour la
somme de cent vingt mille euros
le plus dur restait à faire
la forteresse des seigneurs de brabant
soit était l'un des plus importants
rempart contre les anglais pendant la
guerre de cent ans
une histoire qui a laissé des traces
bâle est solide et nous allons retrouver
le pavage d'origine correct parce que
ces dons et ils sont valides
quand je suis arrivé ici il était
recouvert de sa terre tout le monde le
connaît connais-tu l'état et pour cause
richard passe son temps à chercher
transporté y tailler des pierres pour
son château en 2009 il a fallu refaire
entièrement les planchers des trois
étages avec des amis car notre châtelain
n'a pas les moyens de payer une
entreprise un chemin de croix qui n'a
pas de fin vous voyez là je viens de
refaire l'accès à la chapelle à laitages
le logement du chapelain surfer tout le
plafond qui avait disparu qu'avec des
poutres anciennes des planches anciennes
j'ai refait le sol le vieux carrelage
qui était disparu aussi
aujourd'hui à 71 ans richard parcours
toujours la campagne à la recherche de
matériel
je n'ai trouvé partout
par mon travail
comment un vol vers de twitter
j'ai eu la chance d'aller partout
et j'avais toujours l'oeil averti pour
trouver des pierres des carrelages
détruites de tous si on l'est puis
attend dire l'accord j'attends cette
pierre récupérés dans la démolition
d'une grange servir à refaire les
latrines du château c'est le style de
pierre qui l'a offerte aux et puis que
comme une personne s'intéresse personnes
j'ai proposé quoi voilà posé sur sa la
tournée laisse pas traîner tes guiboles
oui tu sais je ferais pas ça château ne
pourrait pas être historique admettons
que j'appelle une entreprise leur
demande d'aller chercher cette pierre
alors il va leur falloir un élévateur un
camion pas une grue mais presque ou un
machin puis bon ça va te coûter combien
tu veux pas y arriver
restauré seul le château
un choix qui a valu de gros ennuis à
richard il y a quinze ans
il décide de curer les douves du château
en 91
sans camion de 10 tonnes fait mille
tonnes bon il y avait des gravats
c'était une décharge dans les années
récentes des vélos rouillés compagnie et
toutes les pierres des murs qu'ils
avaient abattu précédemment six mois
seront nécessaires pour déblayer les
douves et remonter le mur d'enceinte
mais les monuments historiques ne
l'entendent pas de cette oreille
il porte plainte et en 96 les époux
urbains sont condamnés par le tribunal
correctionnel de châteauroux à 1500
euros d'amendé avec sursis au seul motif
d'avoir réhabilité des douves sans
autorisation
c'est vraiment triste parce que ça sent
mauvais exemple et si vous voulez tout
ce que tout ce qu'on a fait depuis 13
ans c'est presque anéantie oui bon on
changera d'optique voulait travailler
tout pour le château et d'un jetterait
une balancelle et une chaise longue
oubliée la chaise longue mais pas la
rancune des monuments historiques en 35
ans le château de saint nazaire recevra
seulement cent mille euros de
subventions de l'état
moins de 3000 euros par an château s'il
avait été honnête il serait dix fois
plus beaux dix fois plus beau alors on
peut le regretter quand même
à quelque chose malheur est bon les
mésaventures de richard et françoise
parviennent à l'oreille du reader's
digest la revue américaine publie les
tribulations des châtelains berrichon
dans 19 pays
l'histoire de la famille urbain fait le
tour du monde
ça fait un peu pionnier au far west
tu vois ça leur a rappelé aux américains
en 98 il leur décerne le prix lafayette
de 20 mille dollars qui récompense une
oeuvre de restauration exemplaire
c'est une première en france elle était
vraiment étonné d'abord yale voilà c'est
ça qu'on pense à nous pour un prix
pareil et puis bon ça a été remis au
palais des congrès tout ça donc c'était
quand même une reconnaissance du travail
qui a été fait et on vient de loin pour
voir le château richer se débrouille
toujours pour communiquer avec les
visiteurs qui ne parle pas français
bill a comme buffalo buffalo bill les
bisons non vous êtes américains tu vas
faire la photo du siècle y avoir comme
il pèse prend une photo montréal c'est
l'avant
régulièrement richard apporte des
dépliants à l'office de tourisme de la
châtre car aujourd'hui le château de
sarzeau fait partie des incontournables
du berry château
4 happé par la beauté du lieu est en
fait c'est beaucoup mieux que toutes les
paroles qu'on peut qu'on peut dire
autour de ce château c'est vrai tu vois
ça ça accroche un cette image d'epinal
attire aussi d'autres visiteurs comme
david qui a déjà parcouru 1000 km depuis
la belgique
sur le chemin de compostelle qui passe
justement par serveur est vrai que vous
auriez où je pourrais trouver un peu à
boire ou à manger par ail et tout ce
qu'il faut
ah ouais ouais ouais les pèlerins on les
aime bien 20h06 ont rêvé à compostelle
il faut une prière pour nous je suis pas
si on vous l'a déjà demandé mais c'est
quoi qui vous a donné envie de faire ce
à quoi est-ce que c'est quand même un
travail titanesque comme c'est un peu ce
que tu expliques à un avoir l'avis
qu'elle relativement banale d'un beau
pavillon à cabo canapé devant la téloche
ça se discute 1 et donc j'ai voulu
quitter un peu se faire de la région
parisienne j'ai voulu quitter ça et puis
je voulais vivre en province montrent à
bois au prétoire où une rivière
tout ce qui représente la campagne et de
la liberté c'est vrai qu'une vie dans un
pavillon de banlieue c'est pas non plus
exaltant on peut faire peut-être
beaucoup de choses à côté c'est vrai
mais ici quand même il y avait quelque
chose à faire la maison les enfants à
élever le château les visiteurs les
chambres d'hôtes ça fait beaucoup de
rencontres ça fait beaucoup de gens
intéressants que on voit qu'on n'aurait
jamais rencontré
si on était resté à montfermeil ça c'est
sûr
à l'intérieur de la forteresse toutes
les pièces ont été remodelés par richard
avec une multitude d'objets qui attise
la curiosité de ce groupe de visiteurs
américains canadiens et sud africain mes
amis venant de sites web non pas une
histoire une histoire très très
commanditant longue ce qui fait que pour
eux de regarder en arrière
cinq cents ans est une occasion comme
qu'il ne faut pas manquer avec funk et
moi je pense que ce travail c'est de
l'ordre de l'amour la personne qui a
réalisé ces travaux et ce depuis si
longtemps ça remplit toute sa vie et ça
ne peut être que passionnels
vous connaissez salut militaire oui d'où
il vient
aucune idée des chevaliers ah bon petit
mois il soulevait le home
ah non mais ça c'est facile c'est vrai
en mai prochain mais les petites la
petite histoire
oui c'est autant que la g captivant se
rapprocher de l'histoire par des des
gestes comme ça pour des petits faits
ariza s'émerveille sûrement un livre ses
impressions quand même c'est fort à
vivant parce que il y avait des moments
où on se demandait ce qu'on aille venir
comme la seule envie c'est de rester ici
et de m'occuper de tout ce qui est à
faire
je doute de rien je doute de rien
la suite c'est les augures qui ont
décideront 1
il faut avoir le courage l'audace comme
dans la devise faut avoir l'audace de le
faire au moment où se présente parce que
sinon ça passe et puis c'est fichu c'est
simple faut accepter au moment où ça se
présente